arnold and happy days the emperor in
mulan and of course mr miyagi in the
karate kid all of these roles and more
were portrayed by pat morita keep
watching to find out more about this
esteemed actor's lengthy career and his
life outside of acting
mr miyagi is a master of martial arts
he's such an impressive and affecting
mentor he managed to reach kids in the
real world the karate kid's popularity
is often cited as a primary force in the
rise of youth martial arts academies
however morita's childhood was spent far
from the world of strip mall karate
classes he actually suffered from a rare
disease and was told he'd never be able
to walk he spent almost a decade of his
life in a tv ward called the weimar
institute eventually morita received an
experimental treatment that worked
marina defied grim expectations and
overcame the worst case scenarios for
his disease
during his illness morita was often
totally immobilized in a full body cast
that ran from neck to thigh because of
this he spent much of his time staring
at the ceiling trying to come up with
ways to keep himself entertained this is
where morita developed his sense of
humor and comedic timing if it wasn't
for my disease i wouldn't be here today
the hardship of his childhood helped
form his personality and made him who he
was later in life when morita was
released from the hospital with his
disease in check he was reunited with
his family unfortunately the year was
1943 and morita's family were japanese
immigrants
he recalled being escorted by an fbi
agent to the gila river war relocation
center in arizona after a little over a
year spent there his family was
transported to california's thule lake
war relocation center burrito was too
young to understand why they were being
held morita's anger grew as he got older
and began to comprehend the truth of the
way his family was treated
after the war ended morita's family
opened a restaurant in sacramento sadly
his father passed away in 1956. morita
then took an office job to help support
his family after years of this work he
decided he needed to make a change
remarkably marita's sense of humor had
remained intact through all this tragedy
he started working as a stand-up
comedian
those crazy kids huh they eat at home
come here use the telephone no wonder
all the business in the toilet his birth
name was noriyuki morita but he used pat
morita as a stage name because pat was
such a popular name at the time part of
what makes mr miyagi such an effective
character in the karate kid is morita's
comedic timing and subtle humor stand-up
comedy which he embarked upon in the
early 1960s is where he honed that
particular talent morita was known for
his self-deprecating sense of humor he
would often make himself the butt of his
own jokes it wasn't long before marita
got a better chance to showcase his
talents
morita started landing a few bit parts
in film and television in the mid-1960s
they were often roles that would be seen
as problematic and stereotypical today
one of his first ever film roles was as
oriental number two in the musical
thoroughly modern millie morita quickly
started cropping up in sitcoms like the
cosby show and green acres two
particular roles helped him break more
into the mainstream morita landed the
role of arnold takahashi on happy days
and he had a recurring role as achoo on
sanford and son this mainstream success
actually led to a history-making moment
for marita it propelled him into a
starring role on mr t and tina as taro
takahashi this was one of tv's first
predominantly asian american sitcoms
unfortunately the show only lasted a few
episodes but it was an important moment
in marita's career and in tv history
in hindsight it's easy to look at a film
like the karate kid and identify pat
morita as perfect for the role of mr
miyagi he embodies the characters so
flawlessly that it's impossible to
imagine anyone else playing him however
marita traveled a long road to get to
the role that would make him a legend
jerry weintraub the producer behind the
karate kid wouldn't even entertain the
idea of morita playing the role
weintraub's reasoning was that morita
was a comedian and the role of miyagi
was too nuanced for a comic to handle
the director of the karate kid john
avaldson held a private audition with
morita which he recorded during a later
meeting with weintraub aveltson started
playing the tape without telling
weintrap what was going on the recorded
performance convinced weintraub that
morita might actually be able to handle
the role morita still had to audition
five different times before being cast
noriyuki morita was nominated for an
academy award for his performance ralph
macchio
showed up marita's career was taken to
new heights with his role as miyagi in
the karate kid and its sequels he was
even nominated for an oscar morita
continued to appear in guest spots on a
variety of television shows including
appearances on the fresh prince of bel
air murder she wrote and family matters
he started landing roles as a voice
actor as well children of the 1990s may
recall morita as the host of
britannica's tales around the world in
addition to his performance as the
emperor in disney's mulan a role he
reprised in the sequels and video games
like kingdom hearts 2.
he even had a posthumous guest role as
master udon on a 2006 episode of
spongebob squarepants marita mostly
stuck to guest appearances and film
roles after the karate kid but he
occasionally took recurring roles on
television for example morita was part
of the central cast of the kids show the
mystery files of shelby wu in the late
1990s he also played uncle pat on the
barney-esque adventures with kangarati
after a long and varied career morita
died of kidney failure in 2005 at the
age of 73 as fans went on to learn
morita's lifelong struggle with
alcoholism played a part in his death
marita's wife evelyn has said that she
was well aware of her husband's
addiction and that she knew it was only
a matter of time before it took him the
actor himself was aware of it too and
reportedly told his wife that he knew he
couldn't get over his addiction marita's
daughter ali has commented on her
father's addiction as well just like
evelyn she recognizes what a kind and
caring soul her father had underneath it
all she has also said that her father
struggled with being a washed-up movie
star following his karate kid's success
still as she argues marita managed to
earn a little place in history morita's
legacy lives on largely due to his
unforgettable performance as mr miyagi
few who have seen the karate kid can
forget miyagi's lessons to daniel
larusso and the film still plays a
significant role in pop culture the
netflix series cobra kai centers around
several prominent characters from the
franchise it features a scene in which
daniel visits miyagi's grave had morita
still been alive there is no doubt that
he would have made a triumphant return
to the series ralph macchio has said it
was important to him and the rest of the
cast and crew to pay tribute and he's
woven throughout our show morita may be
gone but he is a long way from being
forgotten
if you or anyone you know is struggling
with addiction issues help is available
visit the substance abuse and mental
health services administration website
or contact samhsa's national helpline at
1-800-662-help